hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
immunity against fungus or immunity
against fungal infections
so there are about billions of species
of fungus
but among them only 400 to 500 are
potential
agents which can cause human fungal
disease
so let us look at these species and how
our body mounts an immune response
against them
so obviously fungus can enter our body
via several route such as
entry by inhalation so the fungal spores
can enter our body
via our nostrils it can also
get entry through a injury site
let's say there is some fungus pore and
there is an injury in your hand it can
easily get into your circulation
and lastly it can be associated with
your gut mucosa or other mucosal linings
and they are like kind of a
opportunistic pathogen so whenever they
would get opportunity
they would get in so there are multiple
modes of entry right
now fungal diseases or mycosis are
classified
based on few following criterias so
first of all the site of infection
whether it is superficial cutaneous
subcutaneous
or deep and systemic so these are all
important factor
that we think about then the route of
acquisition it could be either
endogenous
or exogenous coming through our
inhalation
or it might be present already in the
gut microbiota or
or in the gut lining and lastly the
virulence whether it is primary or
oppressionistic so
against these fungal pathogens our body
mount two type of immune response the
electric response which is
limitedly specific and the adaptive
immune response which is highly specific
so the innate immune response components
involves macrophages dendritic cells
neutrophils and complement cascade
whereas the adaptive immune components
such as
t helper cells th1 sub-population of
helper cells and th17
plays crucial role against fungal
infection
so first of all let me tell you that
neutrophils
are one of the component of an innate
immune system that
plays a strong defensive role against
most
fungus so neutrophils are highly
phagocytic
so they would phagocytose these fungus
and try to neutralize the threat
now the three most medically relevant
cell wall components of the fungus
include glucans
mannins and kulti all of these
three components can work like a pam
or pathogen associated molecular pattern
that means this spam would be recognized
by the pattern recognition receptor
present in the
dendritic cell or macrophages
so there are many pattern recognition
receptors such as
tlr249 that can determine
fungal components whereas dectin 1 and c
type lectin receptors are
crucial for recognizing fungal pathogen
associated molecular patterns
so these with these receptors our inner
immune system is able to understand that
indeed there is a fungal
infection and body need to fight back
against that so
these fungal species
would be opsinized by complement
proteins
so here you can see quite a lot of
complement protein has coated these
candida albigans
now when these complement proteins are
decorating the outer surface
macrophages can really come
and bind to these receptors so bind to
these complement proteins as macrophage
has complement receptors
and the end result is engagement of
these funguses with the help of
macrophages
other than that there are mannose
binding lectins
which can bind to polysaccharide type
antigens
and it would lead to fixation of
complement
and the complement mediated damage would
ultimately kill the fungus
but fungus are also very intelligent
they devise many strategies
which can prevent the immune system
to harm them such as one fungus
that creates some kind of like a
capsule around them as a result
the dendritic cell is unable to
recognize it as the first place or the
complement proteins are unable to
settle down on the surface and this
fungus actually
survives and can infect a human
so these kind of funguses are actually
dangerous
now it has been known that aids patient
suffers increased incidence of mucosal
candidities
and many other fungal infections that
tells us that in the hiv
where the th helper cell numbers are low
there it is more susceptible to fungal
infection
that in turn means fungal immunity
against fungal infection
involves these t helper cell mediated
responses
but the mouse which are compromised and
which don't have the b
cell they are not too much susceptible
towards the fungal infection so there is
no extra susceptibility
that tells us among the adaptive immune
components
t cell response is crucial for fungal
infection elimination not the b cell
response
and these days it is well known that th1
subpopulation of cells
are really important against fungal diff
fungal
uh immunity because th one
sub-population secretes interferon gamma
and interferon gamma activates
macrophages
and creates inflammation this
lead to more macrophage recruitment and
engulfment of the fungus and thereby
clearing of these fungus from the system
now a recently discovered subpopulation
of t helper cell which is known as th1
cell
turns out to play a very important role
against fungal infection
because they secrete il17 which is the
key effector against
fungal infections now th17 cells
are generated when the naive t cells are
activated
in presence of il-6 or tgf-tgf beta
but the question is where does these
cytokines come from
and the answer is these cytokines are
secreted by macrophages or dendritic
cell itself
once the dendritic cell or macrophage
recognize
fungal pathogen with the help of their
tlr
such as tlr2 in this case pay this
signaling would lead to
il-6 or tgf beta production
as a result the t helper cells would be
differentiated into th17 population
which plays an important role against
fungal immunity
so now we can understand that how innate
and the adaptive immune components are
holding each other's hand
to combat the fungal infection
so in summary we would look at that
we looked at in this video that what is
the types of
responses against a fungal infection
what are the recognition
methods by which our body senses that
there is a fungal infection
and lastly the mechanism of fungal
defense response
how innate immune system and adaptive
immune system coordinated with each
other
and how it prevented a fungal infection
that we have looked at in this video
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and please support me on patreon
such that my channel can grow big and
big and
guys i'm also present in an academy my
courses are there if you like to
subscribe to unacademy don't forget to
use my code fp10 it would give you a 10
discount thank you guys thanks for
listening